hello everyone and welcome back to the
World Cup this is round five and we have
a very exciting game between Magnus
Carlsen and the Vaseline manchuk who I'm
very very glad that he qualified all the
way I hear the the face Magnus Carlsen
and he's been a top player for like 35
years uh he has defeated everyone not
just defeated he absolutely crushed
everyone he ever played against there's
no person uh has not defeated and uh he
was um okay when kaspar was for example
in the highest rated video player in the
world was was a number two uh highest
rated in 91 and 92 then in 2007 uh when
vishwanathan Anand was rated number one
uh avasta was also number two and okay
he did drop a little bit by reading but
if you remember I often like to remind
this every one of this in a 2016 World
rapid and Bliss championship in Qatar
Doha uh he defeated Magnus Carlsen in
both rapid and Blitz so that's just kind
of what kind of player he is uh doesn't
matter when he plays who he plays he
just uh crushes you and it's only a
matter of which Evancho shows up the one
that can you know Crush uh crush
stockfish or the one that will sometimes
even blunder a piece so let's check out
what happened here Magnus has the white
pieces and he opens with Pawn to D4 for
this game we have onto D5 by vasel
Knight to F3 we have Knights the East
upon T6 and now Pawn to C4 uh
transposing into the Queen's Gambit
decline with Knight to F6 and now Pawn
to G3 Magnus Ops for his famous Catalan
uh Bishop to B4 with check with Bishop
to D2 and now just back Bishop to E7 we
have Bishop to G2 Pawn to C6 and the
queen to C2 now so those are very
standard moves here uh Knight beat the
D7 and now Bishop back to F4
uh we have Castles by manchuk and now
Pawn to H4 uh they usually uh some other
moves uh haven't played here but Pawn to
H for in this particular position is a
new move so already as of move nine that
we have a completely new game and here
uh uh uh Evancho just goes D captures
and C4 usually you would play some like
B6 Bishop to B7 Rook to see it then
Advance the pawn to C5 but as Magnus
didn't go for the standard stuff he went
for this H4 move he just goes D captures
on C4 the idea being that now after
Magnus recaptures he will go Knight to
D5 put pressure on the bishop here and
Magnus of course plays Bishop to G5
saying that he's not really interested
in castling here if um uh Bishops ever
get traded off then H characters and G5
is coming and Magnus will get the
semi-open H file for his Rook so of
course um uh once you're not about to do
that H6 Bishop characters on E7 we have
Queen captures and now Pawn the E4
Magnus chases away the Knight grabs the
full Center here Knight five to BC with
a Tempo on the queen and queen to C3 now
and here with this queen to C3 move
Magnus allows um also This brilliant
brilliant Central breakthrough and that
is Ponte E5 so he plays it and Magnus
was very very unhappy when he saw this
because he thought of course that it was
impossible the square is defended three
times also one of the reasons why the
queen came to C3 and if uh uh if uh
Evancho can actually play this then the
queen does not belong on C3 perhaps the
Knight should have gotten at the C3 and
the queen might have been better better
placed uh elsewhere now the problem is
if Magnus accepts this challenge let's
say he plays D captures uh uh uh on E5
then the problem is Knight the E Knight
A4 attacks the queen and now if you want
to keep an eye on the uh E5 Pawn you
will have to play Queen to D4 and not
Knight D to C5 comes and now what do you
play here it's such a weird position uh
what what could you play here you could
play something like Queen to D6
obviously uh but then comes just a nice
trade captures captures and Knight
captures on B2 so just grabbing that
video pawn and if Pawn to E5 seems uh
like it's going great uh just Knight C
to D3 with check and now you have to be
very careful uh it doesn't really matter
what you do you you it doesn't matter
even if you go here uh then you can even
capture for example King to E2 you can
even capture on E5 if not captures Rook
to E8 and uh well a white Central would
be gone and if you've got something like
King to F1 well then just Pawn to F6 you
mess up White Center and without it the
white is uh clearly worse so instead
after E5 we have just castles Magnus
nodded he said all right uh all right
Chucky you you you you got this one uh
correct so he just castles he captures
on D4 and now Queen capture Sandy for
all the magnets would also love to get a
better Square for his Knight he also
hates his Queen on C3 so Queen captures
on C3 now makes room for the night and
night the C5 we have rooked the C1 now
putting pressure on the Knight here on
C5 and Knight the A6 with Knight beta D2
and now Bishop to G4 we have Bishop to
F1 remineral ring the bishop over to uh
D3 now if Magnus can develop the Rooks
both of the rocks move the Rook from A1
play something like Bishop to D3 Bishop
to B1 plays the queen on D3 move the
pawn uh and go for some sort of a
checkmating attack that would be great
and that is exactly what he will try to
do Rook a to d8 attacks the queen queen
back to E3 and now Knight the C7 the
Knight will now get re-maneuvered uh we
have Pawn to a for preparing Ponte A5 to
chase away this Knight as well and now
Knight the C8 with fawn to A5 and here
uh Charlie trades on F3 once we have
Bishop captures Knight captures and now
Pawn to A6 stops the pawn from advancing
further and now we'll get a very nice
Outpost for his Knight on B5 uh Rook to
A4 SD for Pawn might um uh be a problem
to defend Rook after E8 and now Pawn to
E5 so out of all the moves that we've
discussed The Rook has moved the bishop
has moved the queen has moved now it's
time to re-maneuver the bishop and back
over to this diagonal put the queen
there and hopefully Checkmate the black
king So Knights the D5 attacks the queen
and queen to B3 we have Knight to A7 now
the Knight is coming to B5 and here
Bishop to D3 Magnus continues with his
plan Knight to B5 and now just the
bishop to B1 seems like uh uh you know
uh uh a barbaric plan but if it works uh
why not uh we have Pawn to H5 and now
Rook to E1 adding more now defense to
the E5 Pawn First with Knight D to C7 uh
and now Queen the C2 and this is now a
problem you cannot allow Queen to H7
checks so G6 is played and now Magnus
plays Bishop to A2 you could also
consider a move like G for G4 is also
extremely strong uh just threatening G
captures and H5 and if you captured in a
rook captures on G4 again puts a whole
lot of pressure here on this G6 spawn H5
is coming and it is going to be
impossible to defend this so but instead
Bishop to 80 is played also with a very
nice trick now Magnus is planning Queen
captures on G6 because the F Pawn is
pinned and now King to G7 and knights
the G5 now guarding the E6 and F7
squares and E6 is coming so also a df7
point is hanging so you need to defend
that Rook to f8 pawn to E6 and now Pawn
to F6 chases away the Knight but Magnus
ignores it Bishop to B1 and of course
the Knight cannot be captured if you
capture then I just Queen captures and
G6 with the check and you're not going
to be able to get out of the skin to h8
Queen captures an H5 with check adjust
everything false King goes here Queen to
G6 check and now uh not much to be done
here you're gonna go here age captures
here now with some Rook or even better
Rook A4 the H4 uh you're not going to be
able to defend against mate so after
Bishop to B1 F5 was played and now we
have Queen to C1
uh so how how do you react to this move
what is Queen to C1 doing well Queen to
C1 is such a strong move uh that uh it's
a hard hard to even argue with it
because you have some nasty plans of
like Knight's death seven followed by
Queen to H6 and here you really have to
slow play this you have to play Rook to
D6 and with Rook to D6 you might be able
to hold this position uh for example
Bishop to A2 now you play Knight to D5
and now after Bishop to C4 uh now you
re-maneuver your pieces to go after the
uh the E6 spawn but it's very unlikely
that you'll ever be able to capture it
because uh pretty much all of the
tactics work in magnus's favorite Bishop
Cal person the five okay real capture
Sandy five Queen to C3 check even uh
King to G8 and you have uh I mean you're
you're holding your ground but you're
not going to be able to capture the E6
spawn anytime soon so instead Rook the
D5 was played but now this allows Magnus
Bishop to A2 with an attack on The Rook
which doesn't seem to matter because the
fossil also has an attack on magnus's
Queen We Rook the C5 but now Magnus
plays Queen to E3 and the problem for
Magnus is that he was down to five
minutes on the clock here uh Russell had
some 36 minutes so of course he wanted
uh uh maybe even rush it a little bit uh
but it's hard to say here he played
Knight to D5 but just to show you what a
crazy position it is let's say you try
Rook to F6 because you have to try to
get that pawn somehow Knight the F7 and
now how are you defending against Queen
to H6
uh there's just no good way to do it you
have to give up the exchange with Rook
captures on F7 uh and just hope for the
best because if you if you capture an E6
uh okay you have eliminated the pawn now
even King captures is possible but now
Knight to G5 and you cannot defend now
you're just gonna lose a piece here uh
it's attacked four times the Knight
cannot move otherwise the queen on E7
hangs so you just get destroyed here so
after Queen D3 He tried Knights the D5
attacking magnus's Queen but Magnus just
moves it back Queen to D2 and again what
do you play Rook to F6 okay he goes
after the pawn maybe the Knight comes
here the next after the pawn uh Pawn to
B4 of course the move that wins every
chess game now there are no good squares
for the Rook uh Rook the C3 was played
but now Bishop captures on D5 just wins
out it wins a clean Pawn D captures
Queen capture so now Magnus is up upon
in a clearly better position and uh you
can't even find the move here there's no
move you can make here for black it's
such a bad position uh you can't move
the Knight to help out with the attack
that the B7 Pawn hangs the there's no
really no good Square for The Rook uh if
you don't play anything then Queen to D7
is coming even if you try to stop it
will Rook the C7 uh still you're gonna
kick away that Rook like The Rook a one
Rook to C1 doesn't really matter what
black plays Black mice try to even stop
it with something like this let's say
root captures on C7 real captures Queen
to E5 with check and now
uh that's pretty much it if you uh if
you play Queen Queen to F6 just E7 wins
and if you don't if you run away with
the King then a nice Knight to F7 check
King to H7 and of course Queen to h8
will be Checkmate so uh not a lot of
moves for uh Evancho here he tried Pawn
for this uh gives up another Pawn but
you know he he has to try creating some
chances uh but the problem is also that
move 41 has been played and time control
has been reached so Magnus gains
additional time and uh he doesn't have
to worry about losing on time he plays G
captures on F4 uh and now just Rook to
F5 attacks the queen queen to E4 and he
was in this position animal 43 that the
vasel evanchook resigned to the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
the game is objectively winning for
white and even though okay you might try
something there really aren't all that
many uh moves you could try here the
pawn is has survived the F4 Pawn uh
survives uh just a bad position and I
think vasta was also very much disgusted
with himself for playing like this he
will uh I Believe come come back much
stronger tomorrow with the white pieces
so we'll see what happens in that one so
yeah Magnus draws first blood in round
five of this year's 3D World Cup we'll
see what happens in the other games if
you have a favorite of course do use
hashtag suggestion and I will go over it
uh so yeah uh that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it I would like to thank
you and young Emily
Philip hostenberg and srinivas cash up
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of this spectacular event until
it finishes uh thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day